america's top podcaster joe rogan laying
the smackdown on cnn's brian stelter
after the whiney hall monitor complained
that certain youtube personalities get
more viewers
than well his network
they were saying there's people on
youtube right now that get
more views in this show this is because
the market is spoken
right and your show's terrible brian
stelter talking to the press secretary
saying what are we doing wrong
what are we doing wrong like hey mother
you're supposed to be a journalist
gregory the floor is yours well okay so
this is it's very difficult you know
when your adversary cnn is on a downward
spiral because you no longer enjoy the
spectacle of its demise
because we know there are good there are
good employees behind the scenes at cnn
who don't deserve to be fronted by lying
clowns and public [ __ ]
but i want you know like you gotta you
gotta feel bad about like this a cnn
tech
director or hair and makeup you know who
don't get the same chances that tuban's
got
there are three mistakes that cnn makes
that they should fix and i made some
notes right here
and i'd like to help you guys okay be
honest be honest label your commentators
as commentators our audience knows the
difference between me
and bill hammer he's news i'm
commentating and better looking
there's no distinction it's cnn between
news and commentary
hence why they have no trust because
they're
they pretend their opinions are facts we
all know they also deny the gulf between
their
own thoughts and what they say we know
what chris cuomo really really thinks
outside of his job because we've seen it
he's an example of the phoniness where
he acts one way and gets in trouble
and then he's on the news saying
something else we know that hypocrisy it
has been documented
they also have to address their
obsession with fox right now they have
two employees devoted to watching fox
their devotion though is is in watching
us express opinions not facts
yet they act like we are spouting facts
it's almost as though we are sitting at
a bar
having drinks and there's an
eavesdropper like a little portly guy
with glasses
who's sitting there taking notes going
oh my god i can't believe they're saying
this i got an expo say you know no we're
just
actually there's no gulf between what we
say and what we think that's why the
five is successful
and why cnn is a disaster is you could
see the golf
every time they talk because they're so
damn phony so now i still feel bad about
them
but i'm trying to help you guys did you
get through everything
i know you i know you got more yeah i
got a whole book
i'm writing a whole book on cnn it's
called uh stelter
sucks now i'm kidding because he has a
book on fox but jesse the
brian shelter has an audience of one and
it's jeff sucker
how's matt lauer by the way um and
that's the problem
is that he solely exists to as a
mouthpiece
a useless whiny mouthpiece uh for his
boss
to try and well hammer us take us down i
don't think they can't beat us say
stelter's name cause he likes to hear me
say his name so i'm just gonna say the
cnn guy
and i'm not the same as greg i don't
like to personally attack
by name i i cause i might run into chris
cuomo at a bar and i don't want to be
uncomfortable
greg would be very uncomfortable if that
happened so i will just say this
well maybe i would just i would just say
this
perhaps these guys are cool guys off
camera i i don't i don't know them
but he's a snob brian stelz he's a snob
and he doesn't
deserve to be a snob he doesn't realize
he's being snobby by trying to look
down on someone like joe rogan who has
the number one show on spotify who is
an anchor of a hit network show who who
basically covers the ufc
from right there in the ring the guy's
career is here
and he's looking down at his little nose
at joe rogan who's up here
what is he doing stilter could get off a
plane
walk through get a cab check into the
hotel no one would even know he was in
that city
joe rogan could go he can't go anywhere
without getting pulled over like that
so why does he get cocky and wag his
figure at a platform
that he should actually cover as a media
reporter there's all these new platforms
that have all these great market shares
and and are
breaking ground like rogan is breaking
ground he should actually write good
things about joe rogan
so i don't know what he's doing over
there and i kind of feel sorry for the
guy
which one rogan no i don't feel sorry
for rogan at all
because in this day and age you get
attention by attacking somebody
and i would never do that you would
never pick a fight with anybody for
attention
well i always say if you don't have
anything nice to say come sit next to me
but go ahead and here i am sitting next
to you but
i do have some nice things to say i
would first like to clarify that no one
is in jail for their entire life because
they smoked a joint
but there are a lot of people in jail
unnecessarily for
crimes you're not getting that i'm
talking about stealth though
well i am i am going to get out of it as
a i think i'm the only
person on the panel for drug offenses
thank you kevin no yeah anyway
so as the person on the panel who i
think would be on the friendliest terms
with these people i'd like to talk about
the substance of joe rogan's criticism
which is about not recognizing the
strength of these alternative platforms
which really is where everything is
going right everyone has created a
streaming service we have fox nation
they're creating cnn plus
for a reason chris cuomo and don lemon
have a new podcast coming out right
because they're moving alternative
forms and that really is can you imagine
that
i think you can listen to it next week
oh my god they're sending it to gitmo
they're replacing
very exciting but that really is i mean
jesse's right about that that
joe rogan is reaching hundreds of
millions of people
all across the world he has you know a
bigger bank account than
anyone could hope to who certainly has
a tv show i mean i wish everyone's
success at this table but that's just
the way that it is and that people hate
traditional models and they want to hear
alternative points of view in an
unfettered uh environment where they say
what they mean
rogan picked up on what stelter was
saying because it's the same attitude
about fox news they want to
essentially they can't win in anything
unless there is no competition
that that's how much they suck and so
that's kind of the nut of it and rogan
gives a damn about uh people being able
to speak their minds because he's a
comedian
and he's witnessing he's friends with
chappelle he's witnessing the death of
comedy or was
and told these men with screw you money
step up and say you know what nothing's
off limits we're going to talk about all
of that evening
ryan's doctor gets upset yeah well
cnn took a lot of heat when they started
from network news organizations you know
like
news doesn't belong in cable you know
that conservatives aren't going to watch
the news what is this fox news
and they were proven wrong so they
should they should sit down
and read about it and try and figure out
with curiosity
why is this working instead of poopooing
it it's like
listening to janet yellen rail against
bitcoin she doesn't understand it
you know it's the same thing with all
these institutionalists
who have a hard time with cryptocurrency
because
younger people are sick of centralized
banking and fiat currency
and they want something new that they
are in control of it's the same thing
with podcasting and non-traditional
media i know i've been talking to
young people come up to me all the time
and go what's up with fiat currency
exactly right you go to some of these
libertarian conventions they will say
that well i know that's why i don't go
i know i like 20 somethings wanting the
gold standard back ahead
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else